觉得自己时间多的需要打发这件事情
我就是从根本上无法理解这个mindset
就是时间明明少得可怜
怎么会需要打发时间呢
怎么会是要打发时间呢
时间还需要打发吗
时间不知不觉就都没了
根本就不够用的
所以每当他们说哎我玩这个游戏
我玩二游也就是放空大脑打发时间
我就懵了
我what the
打发时间是什么意思哈
什么叫打发时间
我知道打发奶油
但是我不知道打发时间是什么意思
我这个不一样
和我说的就是你喜喜欢玩二游无所谓
就你有乐趣
但是有的人他不他不这么说
有我也见过好多人
他说他玩二游是为了打发时间
就这个是个很大的区别
你玩二游你觉得开心
那无可厚非对吧
你玩游戏为了开心
但真的有很多人会说
自己玩游戏是为了打发时间
然后你看他们玩的时候玩的基本都是二游
就是这我就不能理解
我当然能理解说你喜欢玩游戏
但我不能理解打发时间就是玩游戏
他不是为了坑
他
是为了打发时间
因为他不知道干什么别的事情
这个是我完全无法理解的
什么叫打发时间
或者从根本上就不只是玩游戏这件事情
就是你干任何事情
然后说自己只是为了打发时间
而不是为了比如说不是为了开心
不是为了快乐
就为了打发时间
What the
可能真的有人认为自己的时间多的用不完
所以他需要找一种方法把这段时间度过了
我是理解不了
这忙死我了
真是
但是就是就是时间是多的
用不完的
怎么会需要打发呢
就比如说我举个例子
就是我特别讨厌那种说做事情要有意义的人
这是我特别讨厌我最烦意义怪
就是说你玩游戏有什么意义啊
你怎么怎么没有用啊
放屁我最我最讨厌这种人
但是就是说你再怎么说你做一件事情
比如说我觉得我开心
我做我喜欢玩
我做
但是就是真的会有人觉得自己的时间是
就是不知道时间用来干嘛
然后他就随便找个事情来打发时间
但就是这件事情我是根本就是无法理解
为什么时间需要打发
就他不是一种说我不认同你玩二游或者怎么样
这个不一样的
就是就是这个已经是一种
就是为什么会有人觉得自己的生命的时间
无所谓
然后花不完
然后就随便找件事情
自己甚至都不觉得快乐
就反正就把这件事时间度过了就好了
这个是最奇怪的
因为我不经因为我们能经常看到一些人说唉
其实我也不觉得玩游戏开心
就只是我需要打发时间
其实到有很多这种言论嘛
说我从来也没觉得玩二游开心过
但是我需要打发时间
我靠我就特别凡尔赛
有一种感觉
甚至就是居然在这个星球上
有人觉得自己的生命很漫长
需要打发
可能会有一种啊这种心理就是特别奇怪
这个路吧建了和没建一样
我不得不说
确实是见了和没见一样啊
幻影机将在那里直接穿着这条路走就好了
Delivery for you to come
And visit
但我说实话
如果你真觉得非常快乐的话
也没有必要找理由
你就说我觉得玩的开心啊
我觉得玩的开心不就行了
不是说话开心是最重要的东西
那有的人玩这个开心
有的人玩那个开心
像我说
我说这种东西是浪费生命
是因为我没有乐趣
就是不是
因为我觉得说这个这个东西我没有意义
没有用
我我我玩
我其实我玩别的
你换句话说在社会层面功利主义上也没有用了
其实是一样
但就是说我只是认为我没有乐趣
所以我不玩
所以是浪费生命
而不是因为他有什么问题
但是就是如果他们觉得玩这个游戏有乐趣
那他们就应该说玩这个东西就是为了开心
那没有问题
那开心才是最重要的事情
我觉得如果你说我玩二游只是为了打发时间
才是更容易莫名其妙的吧
这是真正的虚度光阴啊
但是如果你说我玩二游是因为我开心
那就不算虚度光阴了
所以我觉得后者比前者更完蛋了哈
说实话前者是很是很合理的事情
因为人活着就是为了开心
人都是会死的
说实话做什么都是没有意义的
所以如果有人跟你说
你玩游戏没有意义
你应该去多读书放屁
不要鸟他
不要理这种人
就是开心活着就是为了开心
就要做自己
让自己快乐的事情
而且义正言辞的说
我干这个就是快乐
你别管你管不着
但是但是你如果说自己是为了打发时间
就有一种投降了的感觉
就有一种甘就是甘愿啊跪下的感觉
就是认输
说啊我就像这个世
像这个社会的某一些约定俗成的那种
功利主义的跌位认输的感觉
所以说我个人反正只是说我就觉得
你你说完全没有乐趣吧
也不是你说我以前玩那些氪金
氪金爆肝免费手游
完全没有乐趣
那也不是完全没有乐趣
首先不可能玩那么久
就主要是我后来发现我玩他们的乐趣
不如就是不如我不玩
就比如说举个例子
我以前玩那个什么极品飞车无极限对吧
我后来发现我花了呢
可能两三百小时肝那个游戏
我得到了乐趣啊
其实我花几十块钱买一个极品飞车的
PC上的随便哪一座
无论是你买不羁还是你买热度
还是你买whatever
然后你能你得到的乐趣
甚至是更多的
就是我比起我花两三百个小时
我肝那个游戏
我花就花一点钱买一个买断制的极品飞车
我立马就享受上乐趣了
就有一种没苦硬吃的感觉
就是就像所以像我说的
我为什么觉得我现在玩以前玩那种免费氪金手
也是浪费时间
其实不是因为完全没有乐趣
而是说他们的乐趣太就是纯粹是没口硬吃了
就是我为了同样的乐趣
但是我害自己在那里爆肝几百小时
我有病啊
所以我现在才觉得我是浪费时间
我我当时花的那些游戏上的几百小时
我要是早点去买买断制的正作
我早就享受上了
我没必要受那苦啊
所以我个人的点在这里
而不是因为说别的什么
也不是纯粹因为说什么这些游戏低人一等
或者这些游戏就怎么就是心理洁癖了
也没有
就纯粹是因为我发现
我发现这个有点没苦硬吃了
所以我就不玩了
我就觉得之前花的时间吧都浪费了
应该明明能花来
就是直接享直接享福的
然后我就选择去吃苦再享福
但是没有意义
没有必要
或者说也没有得到什么额外的好处是吧
你说有的游戏是一场苦修
到头来你得到特别特别的体验也没有
就是就是没苦硬吃了
所以我现在就不玩手游了
哎呀我忘了我存在那里的那个箱子
等一下
Now destin your current
Thanks for coming
就要么肝要么氪或者要么去刷东西
就是就是这种
但是明明你买PC主机上面的极品飞车
就不需要干这些事情了
或者说相比之下
相比之下也不是说完全没有这些
但是相比之下就不值一提了
呃
这这这方面的东西就不值一提了
root你就只管享受就行了
我是不是在这里放了东西的
我记得我肯定在这里放过东西了吧
已存放货物
Okay
Turbis falling on my head
不过换句话说
如果有人真的是觉得需要打发时间
随便找一个事情来做的话
你要说我的心里可能还是我有点嫉妒
就是我有点嫉妒一个人
他觉得时间多
因为我不是说这个我不是说嘲讽他
就你怎么在这里
而是说根本上我也希望我的时间多呀
根本上我也希望我我能闲的下来
我能说哦今天没什么事干
我打发一下时间吧
其实就是我没有这种心理
或者说我就觉得我每天太忙了
因为我感兴趣的事情太多了
就我真正享受的事情太多了
但是你要说这真是完全百分之百好的吗
那也不是嘛
那每天就是累的半死
他每天一大堆啊
又喜欢玩游戏
又喜欢看电影
又喜欢看番
又喜欢又要计划旅行
又要这个又要那个
累死我了
我也想闲下来
我也想觉得时间多到没额
花不完
但是我就是没法做到
我没法
我没法有这个状态
所以我也某一种程度上
有一种羡慕嫉妒恨的心理
当一个人跟我说
他要打发时间的时候
我有一种觉得他凡尔赛的感觉
我也觉我靠
凭什么你就能时间多
凭什么我的时间就不够用
我有种这种感觉在
首先你看为什么我EVA剧场版看了那么久
因为我每天只有半个小时的时间来看
为什么我每天只有半个小时的时间来看
因为我只有吃饭的时间
事后来看
那为什么我只有吃饭的时候来看
因为我平时在玩游戏
我所有不工作的时候的空闲时间
除了我处理现实里做的事
比如做一些家务啊
比如说规划一下旅行这种限时时间以外
我都在玩游戏
然后我就只有每天吃早饭和吃晚饭的时候
我边吃饭边看电视
我只有这个时候我才能看
比如说EVA剧场版
所以我一部EVA剧场版
一个一个多小时
两个小时
我看我可以看一整个星期
我只有这个时间来看
我必须挤出这个时间来看
然后我平时就要玩游戏
然后我玩玩你的玩你的玩玩你的玩你的
你看我今年玩了多少游戏
今年我到现在为止我玩了
而且我不止不只是要自己玩游戏
我还要做视频啊
就是我现在不专门做视频
但是我会直播切片嘛
直播切成一个一个的
然后传视频有时候还是要单独做一下的
今年玩了32款游戏
今年玩过极品飞车
热力追踪
当然有一些就是这个界外狂潮就试了两局
45分钟就不算了
临时一文一是人鱼物语13小时
金威车队是24
24小时上行屋上行
战场八小时
马拉松六小时
使命召唤八小时
战地六
但是这个是去年到现在的
我不知道今年玩了多久
Our creators
11小时
刺客信条
枭雄41小时
使命召唤二两个小时还没通呢
这个呃使命召唤二战战役六小时
都市天际线
这个今年其实没怎么玩
主要是去年死亡岛二三十三小时
死亡岛激流14小时死亡搁浅一
其实今年就是看了个生物彩蛋
我只把它算算进去
这个就不算了
然后这个人类分裂
人类分裂61小